hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over the wing game it
specifically in the Sicilian defense you
may be familiar with this in the evans
game it but in the Sicilian it's Pawnee
for pawn c5 trying to control the center
of the board with the C pawn and then
white saying I'm gonna give up material
to get rid of this pawn with pawn to b4
now anytime there is a game but you want
to give up material in exchange for
something whether it's a game in tempo
you have a great development or you have
a strong attack that your opponent does
not see but you want to have something
in exchange for that so after the pond
takes here we're gonna be going over the
accepted line White has multiple options
any time I go over game it I like to
give my recommendation or my
recommendation not to play it
specifically I think there's stronger
gamuts to play as White's if you're
playing against the Sicilian defense the
Smith war game it is one that I like
quite a bit I do have a video on that
game it as well but I thought I'd make a
video for this opening because you may
play against this as black many people
play the Sicilian offense and if you
play it enough you're gonna come across
the wing gamer so I want you to know how
to play against him and then if you want
to try this out as whitey you just like
gambits and your opponent's play a lot
of Sicilian defense and they're very
skilled at it this can absolutely throw
them off especially if this is around a
blitz game or a rapid game definitely
gonna catch them off guard from White's
point of view the main line is to play
pawn to e3 no white is gonna be down in
material but really once black to take
this pawn right here after the pawn
takes then the bishop recapture there's
a few ways to recapture some people will
say go ahead and take with your knight I
like to take with a bishop because it's
very easy to get both of the bishops
eyeing down on blacks Kings side of the
board I can always develop my knight
right here to c3 but this adds a lot of
pressure on my opponents aboard if they
decide from here let's play pawn to e5
which is a common move you can
see the white Bishop is on down this
Bishop can go ahead and exchange the
King takes here Bishop here to c4 just
attacking that key inside the board
maybe Knight to f6 attacking this pawn
Knight to c3 as we talked about and I
think this is fine white is down
eponymous hero but has a very active
board state blacks King cannot castle
why it's gonna be very very easy to go
ahead and develop pieces Knight to f3
castle on the King side his rook can
easily get to any square on the board so
White's gonna have a strong game in this
position now if we come back instead of
pawn to e5 we could see just a normal
development move Knight to f6 just push
forward pawn to e5 and this happens
quite a bit any time your pawn is on e4
or even d4 over here if your opponent
plays tonight you could always push
forward let's say the knight comes to d5
okay Bishop to c4 this is the setup that
you're gonna have the most success with
just having both your bishop
eyeing down on your opponent's king side
and then where do they go from here
maybe pawn to e6 to defend this knight
Knight to f3 here getting more of
White's material involvements of the
game we could see the Queen now get
involved attacking both the pawn and the
bishop Queen to c7 but now I can just
start to exchange material the bishop
takes pawn takes now the bishop can come
up here to f8 as we saw before
exchanging that material the King could
take the rook could take as well there's
different options let's say the King
takes we now see Knight to c3 attacking
the pawn Queen down here to c5 defending
this pawn Knight to a4 attacking the
Queen Queen comes down here castle on
the Kings side why it's gonna have a
good game still down upon the material
but you can see we're chasing around the
Queen both the rooks are active the
Queen can now get involved into the game
pawn to d4 solidifying the the middle of
the board from black standpoint he has
double pawns on the D file
it's gonna be tough to hold on to both
of those so this is also gonna be a good
setup for white another option you could
see is pawn to d5 trying to attack the
center of the board I do like this move
from black I don't like it
after the bishop is already here on a3
if the pawn takes and the Queen takes
now Knight to c3 there's not a lot of
good options for black here maybe the
Queen comes back Knight to f3 you can
see why it's completely dominating as
far as development of the board only
down upon a material but this is not
gonna go good for black white does not
always get the opportunity to take with
the bishop here on a3 if we come back to
the beginning it's recommended that
black instead of taking instead plays
pawn to d5 if you play against the wing
gamete this is my recommendation it is
extremely powerful from black standpoint
very difficult for white to defend
against this as an example let's say
white takes here on Eve on d5 the queen
is gonna come down and recapture the
knight can no longer come to c3 so
before when we move we just looked at
came to c3 this kicked the Queen back
you can see the pawn on b4 is protecting
this square right here now if white
wanted to could take this pawn that's
gonna be a huge mistake once you get rid
of it but Queen to e5 that's gonna be
deadly Bishop to e2 and then the Queen
comes down and takes on a1 you can see
how that's clearly a mistake so the pawn
is not going to take here on b4 another
option that we could see instead might
be Knight to f3 okay just simple
development move from here pawn to e5
from black standpoint controlling the
center of the board maybe now the pawn
takes on b4 which she came because the
Queen's not gonna come to e5 as we said
but now Bishop takes on
for it was defended it opened up once
the pond came to e5 so now a sudden you
can see Black has a very aggressive
board state it's taken all that away
from white white move first we're only
six moves in all of a sudden black is
completely dominating so this is nuts
gonna go well for white you can see just
how powerful that is now if we come back
instead of the knight coming to f3 maybe
pawns who D for trying to attack the
center with the pawns Knight to c6
attacking the pawn
maybe Knight to f3 also defending the
pawn Knight to f6 but you have black
hair they're up in material and they
have a very aggressive board state white
doesn't have anything as far as
compensation for the pawn that they gave
up as the gambit now while that is my
recommendation as you're playing for
black if you're playing it as white you
may not always come across in C pawn to
d5 pawn to e5 is also very popular from
here Bishop to b2 fianchetto to the
Queen side of the board attacking the
pawn if you're gonna give up that pawn
and material early on in the wing gamete
you have to attack as much as possible
so maybe Knight to c6 defending that
pond right here Bishop to c4 attacking
this f7 Square from black that is not
defended except by the king
maybe Bishop down here to d6 you're
gonna play Knight to f3 it's not clear
how White's gonna get an advantage
that's one of the downfalls in this
there's if you look at different options
one thing I always look for in a game it
is how many different mistakes can my
opponent make especially if you're
playing a blitz game if there's a couple
moves they make that they are just
absolutely gonna lose that's a great
game at in my opinion for the win game
it there's not as many mistakes that
they could make especially if they're
not gonna take this pawn early on if
they do I think White's gonna have a
fine game but if they don't they can't
really mess this up and they are gonna
be up upon a material playing is black
that's all that they need instead of
pawns to e5 you could also see just a
normal move like Knight to c6 the
Sicilian defense this is very common so
they may just say I'm not even worried
about this pawn over here yes I got upon
him it's here if you want to take it
back that's fine I'm not worried about
it I'm gonna go with my plan I had from
the get-go but if you decide to take the
pawn on before now they can take it with
their Knight if they want to control the
center of the board that's fine they can
now counter with pawn to d5 and if you
take they can always recapture here on
d5 with or Knight they could capture
with their Queen if they wanted to they
could also say yeah pawn down to d5
maybe now pawn c3 kicking the knight
back here Knight to c6 still not clear
exactly how white is gonna come back and
have an advantage in this spot last
thing I'll touch on is if you're playing
is black you take on b4 and white does
not play pawn to e3 while it is the most
common they might not always play it if
they play Bishop to b2 I'd continue with
the same move that you were gonna play
if they play pawn to a 3 and that is
pawn to d5 if they take this you can go
ahead and take with your Queen if you
want to you still have your pawn here on
b4 to stop the knight coming here you
can also just play Knight to f6 develop
your pieces attacking the pawn they can
come up here to c4 you can even give
back material so you're up a pawn right
now if you want to play pawn to e6 they
capture all of a sudden you get your
light square Bishop involved into the
game you're open up the center of the
board for your Queen to get involved
your Bishop right now is it defending
this pawn here on b4 you're attacking
this pawn right here you can easily
become Knight to c6 so blacks gonna have
a good game they're no longer up upon a
material but they have a very good board
state so you definitely have some
options depending on where white goes
but that's an introduction to the wind
gambit
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
very curious to see if you try it out as
white or if your playing is black and
you're playing the Sicilian defense and
someone tries it out let me know how you
were able to play against that thank you
guys so much for watching I'll see you
guys in the next video